how's it goin breasts my name things
have been going bumping right a lot more
than bump man so bro I'm sorry to tell
you but you are not not crazy here I did
there
I don't anyway welcome breasts of
paranor mother the match is about gaming
all right kill all the [ __ ]
Jeremy what's going down man let's go
now so I got a lot of information from
you bros how to last longer
snake snake what are you doing man stop
it snake no funny thought it was a cat
first I don't know what I was thinking
hey alcohol call how you're doing so
this is my crib you know this is my fire
extinguisher
that's not extinguisher that's my lady
right there pretty creepy girl she looks
kind of nice I don't know what to say
about her to be honest
why was I I'm the kitchen I don't [ __ ]
with me in the kitchen in me again okay
hot cha no well what the [ __ ] well
apparently if you go to bed and stuff
like that you can last longer that's why
I said before what the [ __ ] was that ah
I don't know the [ __ ] have a mom tell
your mom
she always called me when she's drunk
and damn your mom the [ __ ] shares mr.
Chad what are you doing not cool
you're now supposed to be on the table
we are your table owner Shari Shari
god damn you sure Jeremy Jeremy what did
I tell the son I'm so pissed now
no no not it again what I can't move
no not Shh [ __ ] [ __ ] man Jeremy
I'm so disappointed you are grounded for
like two days
[ __ ] going to bed you guys suck you
guys so suck suck so much I mean that's
right now I'm done walking all these
stairs has taken me a million time I'm
going to sleep and then after that I
will sit in this watch what is it mr.
something tell me what the [ __ ] man oh I
get you better sweet Jackson double what
the [ __ ] is going on are you doing the
demon sacrifice I'm so pissed down I got
to go to bed before my battery runs out
you must sleep ignored patient fishy
how's your name he'll call I pick you up
alright let's go to sleep I'm awake now
still the fire alarm
ah yes I got a fix there
Jeremy stop [ __ ] with the light I
can't buy new light bulbs all the time
man
what Jeremy let's just kidding what's
doing that snake [ __ ] everything is out
of control my seriously how there we go
say is it can you that's my paint gang
they take with freaking millions of
hours see everyone here it's busy
this game isn't set done yeah you're
doing he's like another stash ah what
the hell man I'm going to the bathroom
and taking a [ __ ] mess and get a pest
so much [ __ ] this
oh that's right I pissed all right oh
god damn it I'm not I'm not that girl on
her period
all right my toe I stubbed my toe like a
bro what are you doing Oh God
someone needs a good slap itch someone
needs a good slap each other than our na
[ __ ] me what is this
Oh Jamar well why not everything is
outside of control all right what does
it say I can't say because I'm looking
upwards [ __ ] [ __ ] game sir hey
whoa
hey well hey they wait I hear something
it is the world open come on man well
well well
dude Wolfie let's go down Wolfie I just
say let's try this again
come on man work haha what's with all
this static open the door
Jeremy instead I tell you about got a
skull Jeremy good a skull and learn
stuff are you gonna do it
if you all I win my win
well we'd why would you say I got damn
it I throw up or something what Jeremy
not cool Jeremy not cool
dunno [ __ ] here oh I'm pissed now I
tell you my jaw cap damn everybody's
crazy everyone is not a god god I can't
do this anymore breath what anyway like
a baby's you enjoyed the carriage
totally not pointing toward this guy
Cobra today and I'll see you next
episode over ever I'm a thousand rows
[Music]
ah